[Música]
buenos días muchas gracias por darnos de
su tiempo a kim kan podría decirse que
viene casi todos los años como es un día
en el festival de cannes para ustedes el
festival de al menos el mío es
despertarme con varias de mis mejores
amigas en mi habitación prepararme
porque no mintamos no dormimos con
nuestro aspecto real nuestro aspecto
está en modo descarga cuando nos
despertamos
y luego esa alegría defender una
película un montón de prensa sobre todo
defender una película y también uno se
cambió de ropa y todo eso es es como una
carrera una carrera de privilegiados
está aquí este año por varias películas
empecemos por las ampliable dele
ambiciosos que se presenta en la
quincena de realizadores una película
con un universo singular que roza lo
fantástico usted interpreta a ronald la
mamá de una niña que tiene un don un
olfato súper desarrollado en el pasado
de su mamá no sé si la expliqué bien si
a mí me pasa lo mismo trato de explicar
la película lo más claro que puedo pero
dado que es una película fantástica
exactamente que le gustó el personaje de
lyon ya conocía el trabajo de lea a
través de abba me parece que es una
película lúdica uno participa en ella
hay una relación real con el cuerpo y lo
que me gustó de este personaje y de este
guión era una vez más hacer una historia
muy íntima porque hay una historia de
amor es una historia familiar de
reconciliación en un entorno
completamente fantástico tratar de
contar lo que es hoy están en una vida
banal donde tenemos la suerte de tener
nuestras frustraciones una parte
negación etcétera y de encontrar su
pasado gracias a ese poder mágico de su
hija
sanjuán
a muchos cambios
y es así
sí
esto es con el calendario troy davis
creo que esto es apenas el segundo
largometraje de l admisión dijo que le
gustaba al siguiente lea pero para usted
es importante la trayectoria del
director a la hora de aceptar una
película
es importante cuando ya he visto el
trabajo es importante cuando necesito
tratar de descubrir su visión de las
cosas
y al mismo tiempo puedo conocer a
alguien que ha hecho 10 películas no
haberlas visto nunca
y no sentir la necesidad de verlas
creo que con cada nueva película te
arriesgas cuentas algo diferente punto
crecimiento así que no es visceral no es
esencial en absoluto
vamos
es tan malo como así
esto
pero no
por qué
lo que me llamó la atención en esta
película y un poco usual al menos es de
cine francés es que una gran parte de
los papeles en esta película están
interpretados por actores negros ellos
son salitral hawala y matt y mustaphá
bng es en la ceremonia de los césar de
2020 recordamos que aisha maiga denunció
la falta de inclusión en el cine francés
el hecho de que cuando se es actor negro
o actriz negra se ofrecen papeles más
bien estereotipados cree que esto está
cambiando un poco en particular con
películas como las de lea michele
eso es pero por lo menos lo que me
parece inteligente y espero que normal
en la elección de lea es que aunque
podría ser una obviedad no hace de eso
un tema y creo que cuando dejemos de
hacer de esto un tema será cuando
aceptemos por fin nuestra historia
nuestra responsabilidad la obviedad no
es un tema ella quería mostrar una
familia moderna y realista y aunque hay
momentos en esta película que hablan del
racismo a través del papel de mi hija en
la escuela como no es un tema primario
esto muestra lo mucho más insidioso y
profundo que ha sido el racismo a lo
largo de la historia y los hipócritas
que hemos sido en cuanto a esto así que
para mí en todo caso es importante y
necesario y espero que se haga evidente
gracias a elecciones como está
aquí en cannes también hace parte del
elenco de firme fe tú se viene a hablar
de quién team despido de quien presenta
esta nueva comedia chiflada es la
segunda vez que actúa para este director
háblenos un poco de esta película tengo
un papel pequeño y fumé efe s/a se trata
de los trabajos son cinco superhéroes un
poco venidos a menos un poco un poco
desilusionados que tienen que hacer una
especie de encuentro para reencontrarse
para desplegar sus fuerzas y entonces se
cuentan historias que dan miedo y para
eso metemos un tipo de mini películas en
la película siempre es complicado
explicar una película de educción porque
siempre son absurdas y locas el reparto
es increíble todos son geniales y se
reúnen en torno a una fogata al en saba
es una pequeña rata que habla y es un
líder chefs diría yo estoy en una de las
pequeñas historias con david orr y con
quienes ya había actuado en mandíbulas y
condori atilia la película es tan
divertida como conmovedora nuestro mundo
son cuatro amigos que se van de
vacaciones y uno de nosotros su historia
encuentra un casco que cuando te lo
pones te alejas un poco de la realidad
estás en tus propios pensamientos todo
el tiempo y estás mucho más lucido y
ella hace un balance de la gente que la
rodea y se da cuenta de que sus amigos
no son muy agradables y quiere matarlos
en mandíbulas llegó bastante lejos en la
transformación física podría decirse que
no era un papel muy favorecedor
fácil entregarse por completo a la
imaginación de un director voy a ser muy
honesta no me importa la fealdad o o la
composición o lo que sea que haya que
transformar del cuerpo para una película
quiero sentirme bonita cuando estoy en
una promoción cuando estoy en una
alfombra roja no voy a mentir porque al
final todos nos hemos vuelto un poco así
hacemos zoom en una foto para ver si
estamos bien peinados etcétera
pero en el cine es todo lo contrario me
parece muy emocionante transformarme
sino para que actuar creo que mandíbulas
fue la película en la que hizo pinitos
en la comedia antes de eso estuve en la
fia así la plan fue primero sí sí justo
antes las grabaciones fueron justo antes
muchos actores dicen que hacer comedia
es casi lo más difícil también lo siente
así lo vivo como una zona para nada
incómoda pero que era nueva jonathan me
dio la oportunidad de experimentarlo
pero si es difícil porque en mi opinión
la comedia es divertida cuando se hace
en primer grado ya sea por una situación
o por una intención y cuando uno está en
un set de grabación al principio el
equipo se ríe pero cuando uno lo hace
diez veces se ríen menos y uno empieza a
dudar así que para mí el arte de la
comedia es experimentar el ridículo sin
juzgarse estábamos hablando de la flama
siguiendo con ese género chiflado usted
está en el flandes en la secuela de la
flama una parodia divertida del reality
show de jonathan joven hable a los de su
personaje sigue siendo soraya en el de
flan bros
sigo siendo su hora ya sólo que antes
tenía un corazón de mono y debido a
complicaciones me pusieron un corazón de
gorila no puedo imaginarme el resultado
es aún más pues es un gorila es más
imponente tiene otras necesidades cómo
se prepara uno para hacer de mirando
documentales de gorilas y luego rodando
es posible
no sé
en esta película hay un lado familiar
claro estoy en un territorio desconocido
pero de forma amistosa así que siempre
es muy cool sorprender y además cuando
quieres a la gente no quieres
decepcionarla en absoluto quieres
entregarte aún más tuyo es alguien que
queremos alguien que valoramos en
nuestro equipo y también hay nuevos
personajes está acá mirad laura felpa
tomás y meca hay mucha gente que se
estrena en esto además jonathan inyecta
cosas de manera ultra generosa en este
set es fascinante es súper exigente es
un gran trabajador y al mismo tiempo es
muy divertido no es más fácil mantener
la seriedad con la gente que uno conoce
en la flor deje de intentar corte en la
mitad de las escenas y no me molestas no
logró acertar entiendo no sé cómo lo
hace no lo logra me maravilla demasiado
lo que sucede pronto participará en una
película del director estadounidense
airsoft si pronto participaré en una
película de ira sachs en la que
coprotagonizará con franz whisky y ben
whishaw un triángulo amoroso un
triángulo amoroso así es
bajado con directores estadounidenses
con champán por ejemplo recordamos la
presentación de the last face aquí en
cannes eeuu es algo que le atrae cada
vez más profesionalmente la diversidad
me atrae eeuu forma parte de esta
diversidad porque hay grandes directores
también hay un cine independiente que se
está desarrollando y que aprecio pero no
se intentó no tener expectativas
sobre sus proyectos en francia
entrevisté a román joy y hace unos días
va a actuar con él en el leaf gen animal
exacto de toma skate de qué trata la
película es increíble va a ser increíble
también es una película fantástica
cierto
es completamente fantástica los
protagonistas son pole y román un padre
y un hijo que intentan acercarse al
lugar donde está internada su mamá
porque es un mundo de una sociedad donde
algunos humanos desarrollan su
animalidad y se convierten en el animal
que deberían haber sido así que hay
garras dientes lomos un trabajo de
efectos especiales increíbles fui a
probar cosas allá ahí hacen un trabajo
que es arte otra experiencia nueva nos
morimos de ganas de y todo en la gran
pantalla gracias de nuevo gracias a
ustedes
[Música]